Ohio police say they have unanswered
questions after an accused gunman killed
himself he had posted video of a murder
to Facebook Steve Stevens died after
police chase in Erie County Pennsylvania
McDonald's employee recognized Stevens
from a nationwide alert Stevens posted
several videos last weekend and they
included the deadly shooting of 74
year-old Robert Godwin senior in
Cleveland on Easter Sunday Dean Reynolds
is in Harbor Creek Pennsylvania about
100 miles from Cleveland with the
suspects final moments dean good morning
good morning well investigators in this
case received hundreds of tips but in
the end it was an alert employee at this
McDonald's who helped police track the
suspect down I looked out and I'm like
it sure does look a lot like him
McDonald's franchise owner Tom ducharme
says one of his employees recognized
Steve Stevens when he pulled up to the
drive-through and ordered chicken
nuggets and fries the female worker
called Pennsylvania State Police while
other employees stalled Stevens ultimate
was going to be a minute for his fries
which it wasn't really we were just
trying to make sure she got in contact
with the State Police
behind a way surveillance videos taken
from nearby businesses show part of the
nearly two miles pursuit by police they
eventually bumped Stevens Ford Fusion
forcing him to lose control as police
closed in Stevens shot and killed
himself and I think it's safe to say
there was a shot through the head a two
day multi-state manhunt started in
Cleveland on Easter Sunday when police
say Stevens gunned down
74 year-old Robert Godwin senior at
random
Stevens posted video of the deadly
shooting and his reaction on Facebook
this photo shows Stevens in a West
Virginia casino days before the shooting
Pennsylvania State Police say they were
monitoring casinos in their state while
he was on the run because mr. Stevens
was a gambler we thought he may be close
to the casino
we had our troopers on alert around the
clock we would prefer that it had not
ended this way in
the Gators and those close to Godwin
agree Stephens suicide isn't the outcome
they had hoped for police have no idea
how long Stevens may have been in the
Erie area are actually where he was in
the two days before they caught up to
him an autopsy on his body is expected
to be performed later today Gail right
Thank You Dean kudos to the people that
McDonnells thank you very much